MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi.
My name is Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a product manager
in security and privacy
at Google, focused
on encryption.
Today, we'll be talking
about encryption in transit,
how Google encrypts
data by default
to and within our
infrastructure.
When you send a request
to a Google Cloud
Service like Google
Cloud Storage or Gmail,
that request is first routed
via globally distributed system
called the Google front end.
The Google front end encrypts
traffic from user to Google,
and provides load balancing
and DDoS attack prevention.
The Google front end
protects your data
using authentication,
which verifies
the source of your data,
integrity, which makes sure
the data that you send arrives
at its destination unaltered,
and encryption, which makes
sure that your data is private.
Any data that you send
to Google cloud service
is encrypted in
transit by default
from the user to
the Google front end
using transport layer security.
This protection is
implemented using
boring SSL, which is an
open source implementation
of the TLS protocol.
The user's browser
will automatically
negotiate the highest version of
the protocol for communication
with Google to ensure the
best possible security.
So once your data's inside
Google, what happens?
First, it's important
to understand
that not all data in
transit inside Google
is protected the same way.
We apply different protections
to data in transit,
depending on whether
or not it's transmitted
outside a physical boundary
controlled by Google.
When data exits a physical
boundary controlled by Google,
we assume that the network
can only be semi-trusted
and that data needs
further protection.
On the other hand,
when data stays
within our physical
boundaries, we
have rigorous security
measures in place
within our infrastructure,
which serve to secure that link.
Let's talk about encryption at
the network layer, or Layer 3.
Google cloud's virtual
network infrastructure
encrypts VM to VM traffic if it
crosses a physical boundary not
controlled by Google.
The communicating hosts
perform a handshake and then
encrypt data using AS128.
All data in transit at
Layer 3, whether or not
it leaves a physical
boundary, is authenticated.
This protects a compromised
host from spoofing packets
on the network.
Next, we encrypt at the
application layer, or Layer 7.
Google's infrastructure provides
authentication, integrity,
and encryption of
remote procedure calls
from service to
service when those
calls leave a physical
boundary controlled by Google.
This is also a
handshake protocol,
and data's encrypted
using AS128.
Within a physical boundary
controlled by Google,
these remote procedure
calls are still
protected with both
authentication and integrity.
So to sum up our
story, Google uses
multiple layers of security to
protect your data in transit,
including authentication,
integrity, and encryption.
We encrypt and authenticate
data in transit
at one or more
network layers when
that data moves outside
of physical boundaries not
controlled by Google.
Data in transit inside a
physical boundary controlled
by Google is authenticated,
but not necessarily encrypted,
because rigorous physical
security measures are in place
by default. To learn more, read
our white paper, Encryption
in transit in Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]